- It can't be that hard, right?
It's just a little bit of hair.
- Ouch!
- Oh no, oh no!
- A lot of my coworkers
have been pressuring me
into doing stuff with my eyebrows.
- I've gotten them waxed like once,
probably when I was like 13.
- I get, from my Hispanic
heritage, the uni-brow.
- This is like the cumulation of like
me going into surgery
and not being a doctor
and having to, you know,
take out someone's heart.
- I have no idea what I'm doing.
- These hairs on the edge,
they start to get very faint,
but they keep going.
If there's an especially dark one,
like that one right there, boom!
What the heck?
- Is my skin supposed to stretch this far?
I literally am like...
(light ding)
- Oh my goodness.
- Ow, ow, ow!
Where should I put the hair?
- There's like meat on
the end of the hair.
- Boom, look at that.
That's a hair, like on top of a head.
- So do I keep it here and then cut it,
or do I--
- [Man] Yeah.
- Okay guys.
How is it? Yeah?
These really tiny tools,
I feel like small children
are supposed to like operate these.
- Try not to stab myself.
- This is literally like defusing a bomb.
Like if you go too far,
you know, you're dead.
- It's like an afro pick.
I don't know how I decide
how much to cut with this.
- It looks like a Crayola
crayon, but it's for your face.
- I fear I might have
chosen the wrong color,
because it's really
showing up a lot lighter.
- Is it like skin tone or hair color
that I'm trying to match here?
- Oh that's a lot.
- (laughs)
- I don't think it's doing anything.
- Oh shit, that's hilarious.
- That is a glistening looking eyebrow.
- That is intense.
Black was not the way to go.
- I feel like I took
Ron Swanson's mustache
and stuck them like above my eyeballs.
- I think they look good.
- I will probably not
groom my eyebrows again,
unless I get, you know, more
torture from my coworkers.
- I will never do this again.
- You can (bleep) with trimming
it out, grooming it down,
you know, thinning it out, or you can just
color in all the bad parts with a pencil.
- That whole like, (hums).
Is that an official,
like, way to make your
eyebrows look prettier? This thing?